If you're saying you want less fatalities, I would say the
number one thing is training. The result of some accidents is
that people are racing that probably shouldn't be racing and
I am more than happy to welcome people to come race.
But at the same time they have to know themselves and what they
can do and not to stay out of trouble.
That is the beauty of this sport.
That is the freedom of this sport.
The buck stops with us. Flight is that.
To me, it's total freedom. And that means that we own the
choices. Everybody who gives something to
make what we do possible deserts our gratitude.
Whether it's the manufacturers to meet organizers, the
governing bodies, pilots themselves.
They are special. They are your people and never
forget that. Hello and welcome back to
Paragraph Atlas. I'm your host Aninder Singh, and
today we are talking about the topic Safety is a Shared
Responsibility. Joining me on this talk is a
very experienced pilot from the field who has not only seen
evolution of the sport, but along with that, he has been in
the thick of the things from racing to being a part of the
tribe. Bill Belkert.
From racing to be a from race, Just give me a SEC.
From racing to being a part of the tribe.
Bill Belkat has seen it all. Phil, welcome to the show.
There's such a huge honour. Thanks, glad to be back.
Bill, I want to start with the topic by saying that safety
isn't the enemy of performance. In fact, it is the foundation of
it and a lot has been said and done in the past weeks across
various forums. First thoughts?
You know from your perspective what is going on.
Well, I say what is going on is what is always going on and that
is this is a dangerous sport and it's made more dangerous by
racing. And there have been accidents,
you know, ever since I started in the late 80s and went through
the banning of the open class on and a lot of evolution and
glider design. And I can't remember a time
where we didn't have accidents. We always had them.
And racing just increases the likelihood of an accident
because people are pushing it more than they would normally,
which is the nature of a race. Thank you for putting it so
bluntly, Bill, because this was one of my dilemmas as well.
When my generation of pilots or let's say somebody who has, who
has seen the sport only for the past 5-10 years or so, this was
the first big shift or the moment that we are trying to
see. But the question, uh, that I
want to start with is that a lot of us are starting to compare
this with the changes in Formula One.
And I don't know where that comparison is becoming so
convenient, but is this something of Arthur Cena
accident, uh, comparison kind of a thing?
Are we seeing some moment on the same lines in power lining as
well or is this something different as you mentioned that
it is nothing new and it's now just that, you know, people are
talking about it at this moment, so that's why we are paying more
attention to it. It feels more like the latter,
like people are just talking about it more at the moment.
I know the Formula One analogy has been used a lot.
You know, there's been times I've used it myself.
But I think other analogies to other sports might be better,
like downhill mountain biking or mountain bike racing and World
Cup ski racing. We don't have the budget of
Formula One teams to throw hundreds of millions of dollars
at new and better technology and nor do we have control of the
racecourse like Formula One does to slow cars down by, you know,
adding turns or, you know, whatever other method they use,
limiting horsepower on tire types, etcetera, etcetera.
So I'm not sure that we could afford Formula One style
solutions and paragliding because there's really not
enough money in it. Paragliding is not driving the
tech of aircraft in general like Formula One drives to tech in
everyday automobiles. So a lot of technology developed
on Formula One is now commonplace in every car, and
there is a a symbiosis there that doesn't exist for us.
So I, I, I don't want to dwell too much upon the F1 because we
can kind of end up comparing apples to oranges kind of a
situation. So, but I still, I'm very
curious for quite a long time that then F1 started seeing
substantial changes. There were three main entities
that were involved. It was the drivers, of course,
the manufacturers which were wanting to chase the
constructors championships and then the legislators, which was
the FAI. So when I look at it from a
driver's perspective, it's more or less like anybody who wants
to be in the driver's seat wants to go out and chase the glory or
the podium every single time they go out and race.
So they're least bothered about what innovation goes on behind a
car or what are the rules limiting.
They have a very specific set of tasks and their brain is
programmed to go out and execute it to perfection.
Manufacturers on the other hand, do have some capitalistic gains
where they want to make sure that their product or whatever
they are putting out is being seen by the masses as the most
successful 1. So they will push the limits as
as far as they can according to the rules.
Now this is where FAI kind of comes in that they have to take
into perspective every single thing, the commercialization of
the sport, keeping it, making, making sure that it it it stays
sustainable, does not make losses and of course the
entertainment part for the ones who are watching it.
For that reason, in these three entities does the buck stops
with anyone or collective responsibility is still valid,
because regardless everyone is the part of the same ecosystem.
I'm a big fan of collective responsibility rather than to
put it on anyone else. You know, were the pilots in
charge? The decisions are ours and they
should be ours. The culture should reinforce
that because I don't think you get a better outcome in regards
to safety when you put that responsibility on someone else
other than yourself. That should always be best
practice is you look to the pilots first to be responsible
for their safety. OK, I, I really thought I was
not going to bring this point so early in the conversation, but I
think this is a decent time to talk about it.
And I'm, I'm talking about the sad incident that Stan Rods.
Stan Rodsjewski. I hope I'm saying your name
correctly. Stan.
I'm sorry if I'm not mentioned a couple of episodes ago where he
said that there was a task which was flown over a dead pilot's
body two years ago in Castelo. Talking about culture,
organisers knew that there was a pilot who was lying lifelessly
there for more than 12 or 24, I don't know how many, like
because there were issues with his retrieval, with the
retrieval of the body. The pilots who were racing knew
that somebody has perished and is still lying around, but every
single person went out and flow the task regardless of somebody
else. Because there was a comment
under that video where said that the next day after there was
mourning and they stopped the competition.
So keeping in mind collective responsibility, is everybody
just happy being stupid? Because tell me any other sport
Bill, be it F1, be it soccer, be it any conventional sport, if
there is something as sad as a fatality on the field of play,
there is no freaking way every single elite organiser or the
supporters will be insensitive to it and say that let the show
go on. So culturally, even though we
are a tiny handful niche community, are we going in the
direction of shame which is eventually leading us to have
discussions like these and raise questions that why is this all
happening? Because this to me is shocking
and I I still cannot make peace with it to be honest.
All right, what do you know about mountain climbing?
It's a sport. How many?
Yeah. And this is no justification for
task setting in that particular incident.
But if you climb Mountain Everest, you know, now thousands
of people have climbed Mountain Everest.
There are dead bodies on Mount Everest that you're literally
walking by or stepping over as you're climbing.
And there's a fair, you know, there's a, they even have
nicknames for them, you know, which I totally think is bat
style. But for whatever reason, they
haven't retrieved those bodies. And they are fixed, if you will,
on the mountain and landmarks, you know, for people climbing
Everest. And so if I read in the media
or, you know, or anyone else about who's climbed the 14
highest peaks fastest or the seven summits, which is the
highest peak on every continent in the shortest amount of time,
I would say no one's calling out anybody's style for walking by
these bodies. It's for whatever reason in
climbing, it's become the norm and the mountains of the world,
if you're an alchemist or a climber are littered with bodies
and people still climb those mountains.
And so, so does, I would say it doesn't feel on it.
It doesn't feel outrageous on, you know, that task that they
set the task maybe, maybe knowingly, maybe unknowingly, I
don't know the details. Maybe it was the safest task to
set over a fallen comrade. And you can interpret that as
bat style. You can interpret that as dead
or alive. That person is still one of us.
And this was no disrespect intended to fly within the
vicinity. Some would feel like it's taboo.
Some would feel like by flying over that person, that person is
still with us in flight. And so that that is going to be,
you know, you could even feel that that is mourning in itself
to fly over the down pilot and, you know, remember that person
as you're in the area. And I would say that everybody
mourns differently and and that for some people could be part of
the mourning process. I remember a lot of my friends
while I'm in the air. And so I'm sure the organizers
intended no disrespect. Without dwelling over this point
too much, Long story short, at survival of the fittest, things
happen. Suck it up and move on.
Is that the only way forward? Well, but that's not what I said
at all. And I don't think it's survival
the fittest, and I don't think it's suck it up and move on.
I was just at the American Alpine Club dinner, which is the
organization, you know that that if you're an aspiring alpinist,
you're part of this club. They do a lot for climbers.
They do a lot for Alpinist and every year we lose people to
climbing every year. And at these dinners we
celebrate them, we remember them and and we've long ago accepted
the fact that doing extreme sports in the mountains has a
cost. You know, I used to say that,
you know, these sports deliver incredible highs, but with that
come incredible lows. You know, it's the laws of
physics and we don't look at it like survival of the fittest.
We don't look at it like you have to just move on.
We never move on from those lost individuals that will always be
part of us because we were brothers and sisters together in
the pursuit of the thing that make made us happiest, that gave
us peace, that made life worth living.
And so these people will always be, you know, my comrades and
always be in my thoughts if we lose them to these sports.
And I like to, you know, we don't do these sports for money.
We don't do these sports for glory.
We've found these sports because, you know, they gave us
peace. They gave us sanity, they gave
us purpose. And so it's never survival of
the fittest. It's never a callous disregard
for life. You know, in its own way, it's a
celebration of what it means to be alive.
And, you know, these sports have given us so much.
But at the same time, because they can give us so much, they
can take so much away. And so this is, this is not a
callous pursuit. This is not survival, the
fittest. It's anything but that.
Jeez, I love your answer, Bill. Thank you for yeah, answering it
so well. I think I'm going to leave this
here because, I mean, I can say that we can agree to disagree,
but I think what you put out is very valid.
The only reason why I am still shocked from this is that in one
way we want to professionalize ourself like conventional sports
and have those kind of legislations and norms in place
to make sure that we are able to reach those levels of operation
or operational proficiency. But on the other hand, there are
like, there's no way we can mimic them because of various
constraints with respect to money or what like whatever, you
know, the scalability and everything.
And then these parts, I think this is like, for example, you
know, death is a very common occurrence in BASE jumping
community and people still have to normalize it because that is
the only way forward. You cannot stop according to
their perspective. But I think this is where I will
leave the opinion to people and I to the audiences who are
watching this or listening to this on whichever platform.
You're welcome to drop into your thoughts in the comments below
and maybe we can reiterate them in coming podcasts with the
other guests and try and explore this further.
But for now, as far as the culture part comes for me
postally, I find it hard, but I think the way you explained it
is, is very beautiful. And I'll, I'll leave this here
and let people decide by themselves and they can, you
know, start to start their own thought process in the comments
section. But moving on, Bill, coming back
to the point of like who does the onus lies with the reason
why I mentioned 3 entities, pilots, driving racers, drivers,
manufacturers and the legislators.
Bottom line is that finally pilots did have to give feedback
to manufacturers and manufacturers had to work in
tandem with the FAI legislators, FIA.
Sorry I'm confusing the flying and the motor racing thing, but
when it comes to making paperwork more robust, the
capacity, the unwavering, what do you say unbiased stance can
only come from the top of the level executives who don't have
vested interests or commercial interest in pushing one side of
the narrative. So does this not make the buck
stop with the top management which is eventually the
legislators? Well, I would take a step back
and go, what are we flying? You know, and that is if you're
the FAI, which is all of airsport from, you know,
motorized aircraft, through hot air balloons, through accuracy
competitions, with skydiving canopies, we're flying
paragliders, you know, and I often used an Alpine climbing
analogy in paragliding and in Alpine climbing, the alpinist is
trying to do the most with the least, you know, small teams,
single push, minimal gear and moving as fast and as light as
possible to achieve incredible objectives.
And I feel like in air sport, the paraglider is exactly the
mirror of the alpinist and we have the lightest and the most
compact and the simplest of aircraft and we do incredible
things with them, mind blowing things.
And we're literally doing the most with the least in terms of
air sport in my opinion. And so in with that comes risk.
You know, we have the, we have the smallest operating envelope
and we tend to try to operate in the most extreme mountain
environments with the aircraft with the smallest operating
envelope, you know, the most with the least and amazing
feasts have been achieved every year.
It's mind blowing to me on what pilots do with paragliders in
terms of pushing the boundaries of what is possible.
It's incredible. So on.
But safety on is the thing that is the most difficult to manage
because you are trying to be as safe as possible with the least
capable. The least stable of all the
aircraft that you could be flying except maybe a skydiving
canopy, which you're not going to be flying across country.
So I think at times were unrealistic as to what can be
achieved safety wise, even though I do think incremental
gains can be made. If we really wanted to be safe,
safer in a tangible way like many pilots have done, they
switched to sailplanes and sailplanes, you know, it's more
robust, capable aircraft with more performance and a better
safety record certainly than we have.
Because now you have something that is simply more capable with
a larger operating envelope and, and you can mitigate a lot of
risk that can haunt you or push you out of flying paragliders
and still enjoy being in the air.
You just move to a, you know, you move to a better aircraft
essentially. And many pilots have and they've
extended their flying careers or at least pursuits by switching
to sailplanes from either hang gliders or paragliders because
they were no longer down for managing the risk.
And so, so that's one way to do it if you want to mitigate risk.
But if we're within the sport itself and you want to add
regulation, the first place to start is testing requirements.
And so if the data supports a increase in back protection or
if the data supports more robust lines, you know, for G testing
or if the data supports, I don't know something else relative to
aspect ratio, which which has all those things has resulted in
the systems and the requirements that we have right now.
Whether it's the glider rating system, whether it's the amount
of back protection and harnesses, whether it's the
helmet requirements, whether it's the reserve sink rake
requirements for various that's resulted in multiple sizes.
We have an infrastructure in place for the purpose of safety
and and choice in paragliding just like we have in climbing.
And so maybe the listener doesn't know that.
I've worked in the climbing industry for 35 years, a lot of
it and design. I was the head of R&D at Black
Diamond. I was also integral to design at
Blue Ice, which is where I work now, and I have dealt my entire
career with climbing regulations and the evolution of climbing
regulations and how the regulations were developed.
And the result of all those regs over all those years is the
climbing gear that we have now and the requirements that they
need to meet. And so the paragliding world is
not a whole lot different than that.
Maybe a little bit behind it in terms of its evolution just
because the sport is newer, but manufacturers design to the
requirements set by, you know, whatever governing body that
there is overseeing safety in the sport and, and it moves
forward every year and it in part moves forward through
debates like this. And if we need more stringent
requirements, we can always ask for those and the governing
bodies will respond and the manufacturers will also respond.
And so if we are at that juncture right now, I would like
to see the data that will result in change because you can't
shotgun approach these. And you know, is it the harness
that's the result of all these accidents?
Is it glider stability that is the result of all these
accidents? Is it, you know, head injuries
to the inadequate head protection that is the result of
these accidents? What is the root cause, you
know, And if it's a smattering of incidents with no particular
root cause, I would say looking to the manufacturers is probably
the wrong place, You know, because you don't have a
specific thing that needs to be addressed, like the impact
force, you know, for helmets is inadequate or harness is
inadequate. You'd have to know via the data
what you need to change. And so I'm not sure if that is
exactly what you're looking for or is it regulation more of
competitions and requirements for competitions, whether they
be places of competition, whether they be the pilot field
allowed into the competition, whether it's the task setting of
the competition. What is it exactly that we feel
is broken that needs to be fixed?
I'm honestly a bit confused with is this a never ending debate
that no matter what we do, there will be shortcomings and no
matter how far we try to go, challenges because of, as I
said, the other things, you know, scalability, money and
everything else involved will remain.
Because if it is looking at the history where we started the
show by saying that this is not something new.
This is something that has happened time and again and
moments like these help make a transformative change, but
nothing that is a paradigm change in a way that, you know,
it moves a big thing. If that might be the case, then
I think BASE jumpers are doing it the best way because they
don't have any regulation, so they are just going out and
knowing what it is and, you know, doing it accordingly.
At least, the less you expect, the less you can get surprised
at. Well, let me ask you a question.
What's the result that you're looking for?
Less fatalities. That's it.
Yeah, I think less could be achievable and that is less in
competition, less in general, all of the above.
What? What are you looking for?
I would say all of the above because combination is a very
small part of the field anyways. You know anybody who picks up
the wing is joining it for the for the pleasure of flight.
And even though aviation might not be benefiting from the
developments at the top level or the triple C level, but the
basis, the very underlying levels of parallel lining do
benefit massively from the data collected at the top level.
So if we can make the sport a safer place for everyone
involved and not just the elite ones and educate people in a
more transparent manner, I I think we are hitting the point
right there as as we should. Yeah.
And and if you're saying you want less fatalities, I would
say the number one thing is training.
I would, I would, you know, because the same problem exists
in climbing. But there are no certifications
for climbing. It's not like I need to have a
license to go buy climbing gear or I'm going to get signed off
to be able to, you know, go climbing different places on.
Anybody who wants to go climbing can go climbing and buy the
climbing gear. And, and if you're out there as
a climber and you see new inexperienced climbers on doing
things that are dangerous on you try to help them out if you can
on, but you're hoping nothing bad happens.
And so you know right away that a lot of accidents can't be
prevented if they have proper training.
And then you're hoping that and you're knowing, you know, you're
hoping that they don't get hurt, but you're also knowing that
just wishing for good luck for them.
It's not the best solution. Your training is available if
they want to go get it, but since they're not required to
have it, they're just learning as they go.
And so if we want to further reduce accidents in our sport,
training is where you start. You try to train people best you
can, but also know that with a very basic level of training,
you can go fly by yourself anywhere.
And so you try to create a culture in which, and I think
we've done a pretty good job, in which we have training
requirements. Climbing does not.
Climbing has a pretty good mentor culture.
We have a really good mentor culture and in climbing we have
no expectation of 0 fatalities. And from what I hear from you,
you don't have an expectation of 0 fatalities because I think
it's completely unrealistic if someone does.
These are extreme sports in nature.
They're, they're intrinsically dangerous and there will be
fatalities as a result of that. There's even fatalities on
commercial airlines despite a very heavy amount of regulation,
far more regulation than we could ever, you know, fly with
on with the capabilities of what we're flying.
And so zero risk, no fatalities is not a possibility.
But certainly we can brainstorm on if there are ways on to
reduce the amount of fatalities that we have, the amount of
injuries that we have without ruining the freedom of the sport
itself, which is always something I'm concerned with.
You know, if I'm, you know, if it's being suggested that we
need to all fly with aircraft transponders and be under
control of air traffic control on and have our every movement
tracked on be penalized for being too close to the terrain
on, you know, other, I would say on too heavy-handed regulation
on who flies when and where. Or as it was suggested, you need
to have a video of your, you know, of yourself stalling your
CCC wing or any other wing for that matter, to enter a
competition. All those things I think are not
going to be accepted by a community that values its
freedom. Climbers were always non
conformist and anti establishment in nature.
I feel the same element exists and paragliding.
Especially speed riding where people want to go into the
mountains and enjoy them in any way that they can without being
told what to do and where to do it.
So I agree with you, less deaths would be always better, but at
what cost and is it possible? Fair enough.
I think Long story short, if we have to come to a conclusion,
there has to be a sweet spot where the carnage goes down, yet
the freedom and the fun factor does not as much to compensate
it. To illustrate, this will help me
understand this situation of 2011.
You've been racing at the top levels much before that and you
happen to have worked closely with some of the biggest names
in the world. How was the manufacturer's POV
at that time when the human cry was going on as well?
And what was the way forward which eventually lead to these
kind of regulations? Just for the perspective of our
listeners who are, who were probably not in the spot back
then or or like our more recent pilots like me.
So do you want to use an F1 analogy?
That was probably a good time to use it.
So in 2011, the two fastest gliders, production gliders that
you could buy was the R11 and from Ozone and the Boomerang 8
from Gin. And at the time I was flying
Gin, so I was flying the Boomerang 8 and it was mind
bogglingly fast with the trimmers out.
And so the glider like all gliders before had speed bar and
it had trimmers on the risers. And so the combination of the
two, you know, you let the trimmers all the way out and
push full speed, you could get the glider to go on, I don't
know, over 75 Ki could get the glider in and close to 80 if you
had the nerve for it, it was mine bogglingly fast on the roar
of the wind with tremors out and speed bar was deafening.
If your radio was on full blast right next to your ear, you
couldn't even hear it. You know, that's that's how fast
the gliders would go. And I would say, you know, like
F1 in the 70s where there was no limit on horsepower.
And so it was just the driver's judgement as to how much
horsepower was prudent. And so that was the philosophy
of the day is, look, we'll give you guys some incredible speed
capability in these gliders, these racing gliders use it
prudently, you know. And so certainly any automobile
that you can drive right now, if you put your foot to the floor
and went around too sharp in the corner, you're going to go off
the road. And so you have more horsepower
in a production sports car then then obviously you can use
anytime, anywhere. And it's your choice as a driver
as to how to use it. And so the same philosophy
existed with the gliders. And so in normal recreational
flying, I would say you are more prudent on when and where you
would use such speed. It was like, you know, just
driving your car on the road. But when you're on the racetrack
or in our case racing, you were going to try to use all the
speed that was available if you thought you could hold it
together. And there were people flying
paragliders, and I'll use Josh Cohen as an example, that had an
uncanny ability to keep a glider open at any speed.
You know, it was a talent. And some, some pilots were
really good at getting all of the speed out of, you know,
whatever glider that they were flying and not blowing it up.
And so then the rest of us, you know, just had to be more
careful. And most of us were.
And, and then the tragedy of 2011, sometimes I'm surprised at
what the tipping point is on. And in that case, it was 2
deaths. And I believe because I wasn't
there, it was on the same day. And so that that hit the tipping
point and they canceled the meet and banned the open class as a
result. But at the same time, there's
been plenty of other meats and I think 4 this year with one death
on. And, and it's like, OK, if
there's one death that doesn't hit the tipping point, but if
there's two deaths, you know, then, you know, we do, which
which I feel like is, is an emotional reaction, not
necessarily a data-driven reaction.
Because I've been at meats, you know, even Red Rocks this year
where we had one serious injury and we had three other close
calls, you know, that had some luck involved that didn't result
in serious injury. The serious injury could have
just as well been fail because, you know, it was a very serious
injury and it was good fortune that the pilot survived.
And then we could have theoretically had at least one
or two more fatalities if it wasn't for luck.
And so if we had bad luck, you know, at this meet, because this
is how close to the line we were in terms of potential for injury
or death, we could add 3 deaths. And I would say the same things
have occurred at other meets I've been at this year where you
had a death, but you could have had more if it wasn't for just
simply good fortune because you had other incidents that
resulted in injury and those injuries could have just as well
been fatal. And so I feel like we're not in
a very different spot than we've been before.
We've just been lucky and at times unlucky.
So, so, but we've been more lucky and then only when we have
a fatality, which you could say was unlucky or you could say we
had it common, then we react. But the incidents that could
result in fatalities or or not if we're lucky have always been
there. They've never gone away on.
But for some reason now it was enough of a catalyst to 'cause
this debate to come back out in the open.
But. You know, and I apologize for
going on on this, but to get back to your original question,
you know, what was it like in 2011 and what did we do?
We took away the open class and we also limited top speed.
And so they did that in F1. You know, they found ways to
limit top speed. They took away horsepower.
They made some changes with the tires, they made some changes
with the courses. They slowed the drivers down.
And so they slowed us down after 2011 and you would never before
2011 fly the gliders full speed trimmers out in all conditions
on or most of the time. In fact you were in mortal fear
of that speed bar on in trimmer combo on when you were racing
because while there was a lot of speed there, there was also risk
with that speed and you'd hardly ever use it all.
But now you use it all. You know, you're pulley to
pulley a lot with the modern glider because the speed is a
good 20K slower than it was back then and the speed you have is
more usable in more situations now because it is slower.
And so if you're flying AC glider comp, you know that thing
is pegged most of the time you're flying ACCC comp, that
thing is almost pegged most of the time.
But everybody else with you on AD glider is pegged trying to
keep up to the to the floor to the limit.
You have the pulleys, you know, Yeah, sorry, US slang, but
you're flying full speed. And so if you're, if you're a
pilot who is flying in the company of ACCC gaggle in a
typical paragliding meet, which is going to have all levels of
gliders in it, the pilots on the slower gliders are flying full
speed all the time just to try to stay in the game.
The pilots on the CCC gliders have more options.
They can fly slower, they can fly faster.
You know, they're faster in general.
And so they have choice where everybody on a slightly slower
glider is going to fly full fast just to keep up.
So in general, it slowed us down.
OK. A question comes to my mind
though. This is comparable to 2011
analogy that you mentioned that you know, there were gliders,
there were pilots who were able to handle those.
Those gliders probably they had worked for it.
You know, nothing comes for free.
So they have gone in, put in the effort and they are winning the
field by a huge margin where everybody, as you said, is
mortified. But for them it's more or less
just another day in the park where they have navigated that
risk versus reward spectrum and have figured out a way to stay
up top. In today's racing scenario,
there are tasks which are set considering the top 2030% of the
field of the pilot with their achievability.
And then one of the pain points that came up was that the
survivability of the task is not for the whole field but only for
the selected few. But when it comes to celebrating
human excellence where we are putting people on a pedestal
because they are working harder than the others and they have
put in the work, is this some sort of a disservice to the ones
who are going ahead and putting up the work And we are saying
that no? Or is this just another way of
testing intelligence and rather than just raw power in a way?
Do you understand my context? Maybe you could tell me if I've
got it wrong by my answer. When the open class was banned,
I quit flying competitions for a while.
You know, I called it my one man protest.
You know, everybody else moved on.
And I was like, all right, if you're going to take away the
open class, which I felt was critical to glider development,
to technology development on all the factory pilots that you
competed against had prototypes of what the future could
potentially hold that they were trying to validate one way or
the other. And while, you know, you felt
like you weren't ever going to be competitive against those
factory pilots on the next greatest thing, I was as a
designer, I was happy to see new ideas being tried because they
would in the long run benefit the sport.
And many of those ideas are now in, you know, being sea gliders
and also in kite surfing planks. And they were all developed on
via the open class. And and so now on we've, you
know, I felt like, you know, the analogy I was using was now
we're go Kart racing. And so before we were only using
top speed in the straightaway. And now you just fly.
Now you're just going around the track with your pedal to the
floor all the time because you're, you know, the speed has
been limited. And so now everybody's flying,
you know, at the same top speed and we're just all racing around
the track, you know, with our foot to the floor.
And I felt like we were punishing guys like Josh or, you
know, Kriegel or any of the luminaries, you know, back in
the day that were really good at keeping their gliders open.
We were taking away something that they were good at because
all of us weren't good at it. And so now we were taking, you
know, their talent and their advantage off the field and
making it a better race for us mortals and a worse race for
them. But you know, after, you know, a
decade plus, you know, because I only just got an Enzo 3 last
year after a decade plus of sort of watching this from the
sidelines in pursuing more cross country flights on a Zeno AD
glider, the cream rose to the top anyway, you know, and so the
top pilots, even though we took away things that they were good
at and leveled the playing field to the mortals advantage, they
found a way to win anyway because they were talented.
And so I, I went to the Super final in Columbia last year and
that was the, I know, the first PwC style race with all the top
European pilots that I've been to in over a decade.
And I was amazed how the top pilots still found an advantage
even though I was on exactly the same kit that they were on now.
Submarine Enzo on most of the field was on, you know,
submarines and Enzos or X ones and Genie race fives and, you
know, boom, twelves and all the gliders and the harnesses went,
you know, similarly. And this was the closest thing
to a level playing field in a top World Cup race that I've
ever been to. You know, back in the day it was
very different with open class. And so here I am with the same
kit as everybody, and the gaggles never broke up.
You know, it was one giant Armada flying around the course.
But the winners, like Maxime, still found a way to get to the
front of that thing. And it was it was amazing to
watch. And so I was very pleased to see
that the the best pilots in the world still found a way to win.
So even if it might look in short notice that we are taking
away advantage of some people who truly deserve it, if it is
for the greater good, it is more or less justified in a way.
Just yeah, I agree. It took me a while to get there,
but taking away the open class didn't ruin everything, you
know? And so I felt it was going to
ruin everything and it only slowed it down.
And so that Enzo's, what, 6 years old going on 7 now, 8, you
know, we would have never seen a glider hang around that long
back in the day of open class. Change came way more rapidly
because there was less limitations.
There was more experimentation on and that is the one result of
CCC is it slowed everything down.
And so we we have that, but I'm not saying that that is
necessarily a bad thing, but that is one of the side effects
is more requirements, more standards will slow down on
evolution. It's a, it's a limitation, you
know, like you put a limitation on a system you're, you know,
it's guardrails and so, but you could say that there's benefit
to going slower, you know, and so, but that is a result.
That's like a catch 22, especially for the ones who want
to go out and chase fun. I mean, of course, we will make
people, we will drive away the ones who are chasing adrenaline
at the highest level. Like, you know, there were
people who were able to keep their bladder open.
I'm sorry, I keep forgetting the name of the pilot that you
mentioned who was so skilled. But yeah, like, for the sake of
inclusivity and for like, making sure more people are able to
experience this, it seems like it's OK to sacrifice a few.
But again, I think this is another one of those never
ending debates, which is more or less subjective.
So maybe audience members can help us in this one as well and
give out their, you know, point of view in the comments section
because I think a lot of this is already being discussed in the
pilot's union, which has recently found up.
Speaking of which, will there have been some, you know, ray of
hopes coming up in the past few days where a lot of solutions
are discussed at various levels of hierarchy.
Pilot's union was something that was never heard of.
In fact, I think today at the time of recording this episode,
FAI put out a public post that they're going to have a pilot
relationship officer, which Violetta has been chosen for.
So there are, we are seeing some changes coming into place
already. But looking from from your
experience, where do you see as as an origin necessity or like
which are the ones that should be prioritised if we want to get
back to having fun as we are supposed to rather than
scapegoating of some sorts of finger pointing and that we are
at the risk of doing at or anyone is in debates like these,
I would say. Well, I would say I've got no
magic bullet for this or, or profound, you know, easy
solution because I feel like there's no easy solution.
And one of the things, you know, that comes to mind is on how we
treat competition itself. And so, and this is just fully
anecdotal on my part, I feel that more paralorder pilots fly
in competition just as part of what they do in a given year.
Then mountain bikers participate in mountain bike races as part
of what they do in a given year or skiers participating in ski
racing as part of what they do in a particular year of skiing.
So I think a higher percentage of Parabutter pilots go to races
than other extreme sports. And because it's, it's more than
just a race, you know, it's sort of a community gathering.
You go to these races to fly with your friends.
It's it's just more popular to do in paragliding than other
sports. And as a result is you have on a
big cross section of pilot skill in a, in a any given race, you
know, even on even the PwC, which has the highest level of
qualification to get in. We always knew that if you
really wanted to get into PwC, just go to the less popular ones
in the faraway places that have the most chance of not filling
up. And you know, you can have a
better shot at getting in. You know, they're still going to
look at you to see if you're up to it, but it's not going to be
as difficult to get into the, you know, to the race in Utah
last year as it is to get into the race in Spain, You know,
this year when the, you know, the top European pilots are
going to attend the Spain one en masse.
And so, you know, your ladders have to be really good to get
in, but your ladders to get in Utah don't have to be that good.
And so you can get in to the PwC even if you're not a a top
racer. As Goran said, and I totally
agree with them, everybody has to do their first PwC sometime.
It's not like you're going to come into APWC having done
others. If you're in a rising pilot, at
some point they're going to have to let you in as part of your
evolution as a pilot. So you're going to be new,
everybody's new at some point. And so, so you can get, you
know, pilots of average skill in a top race.
And then those races are going to be designed, you know, to
test the top of the field. And then you're going to hope,
pray that the pilot's not at the top can keep themselves out of
trouble because they're pilots and they could make safe
decisions for themselves. So it, and this is a problem we
have and I wouldn't say that it is the result of all accidents
because obviously it's not, but it's the result of some
accidents is that people are racing that probably shouldn't
be racing. And I am more than happy to
welcome people to come race. But at the same time they have
to know themselves and what they can do enough to stay out of
trouble. And you know, that's a tough
thing to regulate. So, so, so the bottom line is we
need to, it's either through communication or it's through
culture and evolution in culture that it's maybe having more fly
insurance and gatherings that are options for people instead
of going to races and having them treat those like fly
insurance and gatherings instead of races.
The CC, well, the, the sea glider meets could provide more
options for pilots. And that is, it's not that we
need to go to CCC from CCC meets to Sea Glider meets, but the
mere existence of the sea Glider meets and I would say less
hardcore racing and more fun gives an outlet for for people
to choose that over going to ACCC meet.
And so you get sort of better alignment with the pilots in the
venue than we currently have. And, you know, that could that
could make a difference. But I saw some things this year,
you know, that just weren't a result of racing at a, you know,
at a too high of a level, you know, and that is sea gliders on
just taking frontals just after launch, you know, in typical,
you know, midday thermic conditions that resulted in
serious injury. You know, and the US wasn't the
only place that it happens. Or I just AD glider on having a
deflation and the pilot just never throws to reserve plenty
of room to throw on, but for reasons unknown, you know, just
spiral into the ground and and you're going.
All right. Well, there's 2 examples where a
different format wouldn't have helped, or more glider
certification requirements wouldn't have helped, or banning
the CCC gliders and making everybody fly sea gliders
wouldn't have helped. And so, you know, you're instead
of just overreacting and going, all right, we're going to burn
this thing down and start over. You're sort of looking for some
correlation in the data that points to a specific problem
that you can actually address. Then just an emotional reaction
that this whole thing is broken and we need to fire everybody
and start over or regulate the shit out of it at every level to
try to fix this. And, and I'm going all right.
Is that really going to make it better or?
Are we just in denial, you know, as to what it is that we're
doing and or does the answer just lie in the middle?
Sweet spot as we said it, but I think you put a lot of very
valid points out there beautifully, Bill.
And I'll leave the audiences to process it for a bit.
But before we close for the day, Bill, I want to bring this point
out because in PwC Turkey edition, there was just one
woman pilot and she was naturally probably the first in
the women rankings and she was flying a yatta advance yatta, A
high B if I'm not mistaken. Please don't quote me on this, I
haven't researched this very well but.
No, I was a stranger. Indeed so.
And kudos to the women pilot. She wants to, you know, become a
racer. She wants to put herself for the
best of the best. It takes a lot of courage to do
that, but a high B pilot is allowed in the same gaggle as
the top of the line triple C's. Is this the pilot's
responsibility for being too ambitious?
Or is this the organiser saying that we will accept everyone
because we want to promote and welcome everyone?
Because to me, this can't be. Yeah, this kind of a stalemate
is a bit weird, man. Like I'm not able to make peace
with this. That who should be questioned on
this regard because it does feel out of place for me at least.
Well, I was in Turkey and you know, my first PwC.
So this was and of course you asked me a question.
You get a long story. I apologize for that.
But my first PwC was 1992 in the Owens Valley.
And and I, I, I jokingly say it was my first PwC because I
wasn't allowed to fly in it, but they did let me win dummy.
And so it's the Owens Valley, you know, I think it's the fall
and I'm wind dummying for the PwC because I'm not good enough
to fly in it, but I'm good enough to launch just before
they launch and be in the air 1. The bunch of them launch and I
can't fly the task obviously on. So, you know, I just fly around
a bit around the launch area and go out and land every day.
But I'm flying in the same era. I'm just not flying the task.
And so and I was, you know, very proud to be able to make a
contribution to the PwC, you know, with respect to, you know,
just going out there and win dummy and forum so they could
have a good race. And so it was part of the
learning curve and it was great to be there.
And so in Turkey for the one woman in the meet on, you know,
the bee glider conditions are very reasonable to go flying.
And so if this was a normal recreational flying day without
a competition, she would have been out there flying.
You know, conditions weren't extreme.
And when you're, when you're in the PwC, you know, if you're on
a bee glider, you're not even in the race really.
You just sort of win dummy in the course because you're not
going to be in anybody's way because you're usually lower or
behind. And so you're participating, you
know, this is, but you're not, you know, you're not racing
racing, but you're participating and you're on seeing what it's
all about. You know, you're seeing, you're
getting experience. You know, and this is Goran's
analogy, you know that it's, it's always, you know, for the
best pilots in the world, you know, they still had their first
PwC at some point. And so I didn't feel like it was
dangerous for her. It was dangerous for us that she
was there on, you know, there were other sea gliders in the
meat and I didn't feel like they were any in position to us or
they were a danger to themselves.
They would have gone flying on the same kind of the day.
And so I don't think there was a need to be exclusive with
respect to, you know, to it being a PwC.
And these people shouldn't be there.
I felt it was great that they were there.
And it's not to me, that's not where the danger is, you know,
because because they kept themselves out of trouble.
And this is, you know, comes back to the very beginning of
the conversation, even before you started recording about it's
the pilot in charge that's the most important.
Because you could participate in APWC and not get in anyone's way
and not be a hazard to yourself and go have a good time flying
because it is a good flying day. And just because it's also a
race doesn't mean that you can't go flying and keep yourself out
of trouble because you're a pilot, you're a certified pilot
and you should be able to go flying on a good day and keep
yourself out of trouble. And so, so to me, that's that's
the the bottom line. And if we're talking about going
racing on marginal days and taking additional risk because,
you know, you wouldn't normally be flying on a day like this and
now you're feel like you're being forced to because
everybody else is, it's a bit of a different conversation.
We could have that another time because it's a valid one.
But in the case of Turkey, it was good flying.
And so I was glad she was there. She did great.
Amazing. Bill, I think, you know, I love
the way you answer these questions because before this
conversation, these were burning questions that to me, nobody was
able to clarify and I was just living with the anxiety that
comes with unanswered questions. But I think the way you put
through facts is it's just fascinating, man.
This is magical to see somebody bring out their perspective like
this. But closing thoughts, Bill, time
and again, we have said this and tried to address it from
multiple point of views, but the bottom line is the buck stops
with us. Is that what you're saying
eventually? Yeah, it does.
And that is the beauty of this sport.
That is the freedom of this sport.
The buck stops with us, you know, and I'll use as the last
example on Gavin, he runs the Red Rocks wide open and then
shortly after they do the X Red Rocks, which is the hike and fly
race and so on. You know, one race the wide
open, you have a task committee and a safety committee and a
fairly big infrastructure in terms of rescue services and
volunteer support. Glider fluffers on launch on a
lot of on support for the pilots and a lot of work for the
organizers to try to provide as a safe of a competition as
possible where the organization is making more decisions for the
pilots. And so we had one serious
accident and a few really close calls that could have gone
either way. And, and so we, we finish up
that meet and then a week later Gavin does the ex red rocks.
And now there's no task. There's a task committee, but
there's no safety committee. There's no regulation of what's
launchable conditions or not or, or anything other than giving
weather briefings and let pilots make their own choices as to
whether they're hiking or whether they're flying.
And they get through that meet with one incident which a pilot
threw his reserve but was fine and kept packed up and kept
hiking. And so no injuries and, and, and
I couldn't help but go, all right, well, there was one meet
where we were making a lot of decisions for the pilot field
and we had a mixed bag of results.
And there was another meet where the pilots made entirely their
own decisions and they had less incidents.
And it and, and I had made some kind of comment via text to
Gavin. And all she said was, yeah,
completely different group. It's all he said.
And I took that as it's like, look how powerful that is when
the pilots own it and have the choice of hiking or flying or a
little bit of both. Look how well they can do when
they know it's on there or you look at those big flights done
on those inspiring flights I talked about earlier all over
the world, whether it's flying off the summit of K2 or Nanga
Parbat. And I know that wasn't the
summit, but it's still a fantastic flight by David or on
or Antoine's, you know, Volbev across the US or, you know,
breaking Triangle records or, you know, big flights in
Pakistan. All of those were done without
anybody telling the pilots what they should do and when they
should do it. On the pilots themselves, you
know, they created the inspiration and, you know, they
had the inspiration and then they pulled off the flights.
And so to me, it it comes down to the pilot.
And that is also the beauty of the sport on, you know,
mountaineering, freedom of the hills.
You know, this is when I got into climbing and it was, there
was one line in it and it said take a step in any direction and
experience the freedom of the Mountaineer and flight is that
to me, you know, it's total freedom.
And that means that we own the choices.
It's fascinating, man, fascinating to hear that Bill,
because deep inside we all know us better than anyone else and
that reality is not going to change ever.
So let's all try to bring in the professional discipline that our
actions deserve, and that's all going to be collectively.
Yeah, really nice. You forge yourself through these
sports, you know? You know, to do that, the fire's
got to burn pretty hot. And the fire is the risk that's
involved to create the heat, to allow the metal to move.
And you basically remake yourself via these sports
because you have to manage yourself.
You have to know yourself and what you can do.
And that that evolves over time but keeps you humble.
It keeps you completely honest with yourself as to what you can
pull off. And even with all of that, the
risk remains, but that risk is the fire that has changed you.
And, and I would say that any of us that have participated in
this activity, whether we're still alive or not, have been
forever changed from it and forever benefited from it.
And so, you know, this is, you know, part of the cost of, you
know, the pursuit of an extreme sport in nature.
But, you know, because you're not with us any longer doesn't
mean that it hadn't had a profound and beneficial
influence on your life and created bonds with your friends
that have could never been created any other way.
You know, when you're with people in the sky on a big day
on their, there's a connection there that cannot be formed any
other way. And you'll see this when you're
together, you know, with your comrades in flight, whether
you're walking through the town of Shamani, you know, you could,
you know, that look of a fellow alpinist or a fellow pilot that
has been transformed, you know, by the sport.
And there's a connection to them, even if you don't know
them personally. You see each other on the
street. You recognize each other.
You, you have a bond that cannot be formed any other way.
And you know, these people are your brothers and sisters
forever, you know, even if you've never spoken a word to
them. And this is, you know, this is
one of those gems that the sport gives us, but it doesn't give us
those without a cost. And, you know, the only thing I
can, you know, ask people to consider is the totality of the
gift of this activity. And you're going to lose
something if you try to pick at it or change it too much to fix
what you don't like, because you might do that at the expense,
you know, of what makes it special.
And so you know. So in closing, I I would say
that everybody who gives something to make what we do
possible deserves our gratitude. Whether it's the manufacturers,
whether it's the volunteers, whether it's to meet organizers,
whether it's the governing bodies that usually are, you
know, pilots themselves, whether it's the tribe, everybody that
you're flying with, they are special.
You know, they are your people, and never forget that.
Wise words, Will, wise words. I think this is what I told you
last time as well, because speaking with you is so
fascinating, magical and enriching all at once that the
only bad part of all this episode is that it has to come
at an end at a certain point. And for for our audiences who
are watching us and listening to us right now.
There was a episode that I recorded with Bill a couple of
months ago when I was when we were at PwC in Macedonia.
I was not racing by the way, but that has still remained
unreleased because of some of the priorities that came up in
the show. Uh, but that magic will come
your way and umm, please let us know how you like this
discussion, because to me this has been one of the most eye
opening ones ever since I started the show and having
somebody of bill's stature is always an absolute honor.
So umm, all I can say is until next time bill.
Thank you so much for this. It's been an.
Honor. All right, man.
Thanks for having me.